Subclassing was really easy when we were using the functional pattern here.
But let's explore how we might do this if we were using the pseudo-classical
pattern for our base class.
How do we go about writing pseudo-classical subclasses?
For practice, let's start this program from scratch.
It'll be good to build up the program one line at a time, anyway.
Since the pseudo-classical code we're about to write is going to look so
different from the functional code we already wrote.
Furthermore, let's use some different sample code in our run.js file.
It'll be easier to think about this if we're only instantiating one instance of
the superclass and one instance of one of the subclasses.
So just like before, Van is a subclass of Car.
Amy is an instance of van, and this new zed object will be an instance of a car.
We won't examine the cop class here, or any instantiation of it,
because we only need to see one example of a subclass to make the point.
By reading this first line of code,
I can tell that I'm going to need a car function to make instances of cars and
it'll take an input to use as a location for the new car.
Inside the Car function we will do the work that is specific to
one instance of a car.
In this case, adding a property that should be different across all cars.
But what about that move property that Car instances like zed appear to need?
Take a moment to decide where you think you would add that functionality for
this pseudo-classical Car class.
Edit the car class so
that it exhibits the move function that we remember from before.